hello Internet you're watching mostly
weekly i'm andrew heaton solamente
lagunas basics cuba known as Cuba
Canadians Cuba to Kennedy's and daddy to
Cuba Gooding jr. jr. Cuba's famous for
rum salsa beaches and human rights
violations and it's for one of these
reasons that the US has an embargo
against the whole country it's the last
reason the Obama administration restored
diplomatic ties with Cuba in 2014 he
removed it from the terror list and
removed travel restrictions last year
600,000 Americans visited Cuba but now
President Trump is reinstating some of
those restrictions American tourists can
only travel to Cuba with a government
approved tour group and have to keep all
of the receipts and itemized at inner
Ares for five years so we're going to
restrict the freedom of people to show
that restricting the freedom of people
is wrong most of trumps Cuba policy
consists of landing in fact he's only
partially undoing Obama's reforms but he
might go further America's embargo on
Cuba kicked off in 1958 which means if
singer-songwriter ed Sheeran were a unit
of time the embargo is now to Ed
Sheeran's old so what have we learned in
these past Sheeran's we learned that the
Cuban embargo doesn't work but even if
it did it shouldn't exist I should be
able to buy stuff from whoever I want
and I just so happen to like Cuban
cigars
[Music]
director and as a free citizen I should
be able to travel to any country and/or
planet we're not at war with there are
countries with terrible human rights
records that we can still travel to
Venezuela Iran Mordor now some people
think these restrictions of our freedom
are justified because the embargo hurts
a dreadful communist regime only problem
is it doesn't the Cuban embargo doesn't
hurt communist leaders it hurts the
Cuban people especially the port food
shortages led to a 33 percent drop in
caloric intake between 1989 and 1993 the
man makes it hard for the poor today to
access necessities like medical supplies
toilet paper and digit spinners in Cuba
can already trade with the rest of the
world so if they want a Western good
they can just trade with Europe for
their fix of wooden shoes silly monarchs
alcoholism and war memorials so the
embargo is hurting them but it's also
hurting us the US Chamber of Commerce
estimates that each year the embargo
costs the United States 1.2 billion in
sales and exports the embargo is the
international equivalent of trying to
get what you want by holding your breath
the embargo is a relic of Cold War
thinking like huge military spending or
homoerotic volleyball scenes it's been 2
and 1/2 Kendall Jenner's and still the
embargo has failed to achieve its goal
of pressuring Cuba to adopt a
representative democracy but the
communist government can use the embargo
to blame America for its own dumbass
socialist failures and look we're all on
board about hating Communists is a
terrible system and the Cuban government
in particular is a human rights disaster
plus it's so humid in any case the fact
that Cuba's government sucks doesn't
make the embargo a good idea but Donald
Trump and others want to keep the
embargo and the travel restrictions
going so here's what I propose
if you want to keep the embargo go ahead
Donald Trump feel free to not visit Cuba
as much as you want anyone who wants to
keep the band can be my guest as for me
I'm going to enjoy a nice Cuba Libre
well but mostly I'm Andrew he ought to
luego
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]